i was going through a period in my life  where i just didn't have a lot of  friends um i was having body  insecurities that were just really kind  of tormenting me um and this led me to  go online a lot i kind of stopped having  friends in the real world i stopped  really engaging in school and i turned  to internet communities to being able to  participate in those social communities  you have to really agree with the gender  ideology and  there's a lot of social incentives to do  something like um change your pronouns  from a she her to a they them that's a  very small step that isn't an instant  commitment to like becoming a boy or  transitioning so that's how it started  for me i felt that kind of social  pressure and so i did start to change my  pronouns um and it took two or three  years before i actually reached that  place where i was like i'm a boy